new video game adaptations prequels to a
popular show and one of the most famous
book and film series of all time more
star wars stuff there's lots of new
shows coming out this year how will a
jedi knight return to our screens keep
watching to find out
fans of j.r.r tolkien's epic fantasy
adventure series and peter jackson's
subsequent film adaptations are in for a
treat the lord of the rings is returning
to live action once again this time as
an amazon prime series however this
isn't a simple recreation of the path
that's already been well tread by
jackson and crew while there isn't much
detail about the plot at all as of the
making of this video we do know from
amazon's release of a serious companion
map that it is set thousands of years
before the events of the hobbit or the
lord of the rings during a time when a
shadowy evil was attempting to sow its
seeds among the hills of middle earth
much like sauron's conquest in the
popular trilogy the show will of course
present a wholly new cast of characters
with an original story that is bound to
set itself apart from the films that we
all know and love the lord of the rings
series debuts in september and promises
to be one of the most expensive tv
series ever made according to the
hollywood reporter the first season
alone has a production price tag coming
in at
465 million dollars
marvel is plotting along continuing
their lucrative vortex that is the mcu
constantly spitting out all sorts of
projects disney plus is offering a
smattering of new marvel-centric shows
in 2022 including she-hulk tatiana
maslany plays the role of jennifer
walters a lawyer for metahumans who
ultimately becomes she-hulk as part of
phase 4 of the mcu she-hulk season 1
will come packed with 10 episodes via
discussing film kevin feige shared that
she-hulk opts to take a bit of a
different tone from the traditional
marvel fair as it will lean heavier into
the comedic side of the marvel world
she-hulk fans will also see mark ruffalo
reprise his role as bruce banner as well
as tim roth returning as the abomination
per the hollywood reporter for those who
remember the earliest hulk film in the
mcu that originally starred edward
norton in this role roth played emil
blonsky who transformed into the
sinister abomination as is typical of
marvel productions there's likely to be
many cameos and interactions with other
mcu characters throughout the show as
the creators behind marvel productions
are always throwing surprises at
audiences
the last of us is an ultra popular
playstation game developed by naughty
dog the game has earned countless awards
for not only its game mechanics but the
depth of the writing and the journey of
the game's lead characters if any video
game was made to be adapted into an epic
drama it's the last of us hbo snapped up
the property due to its enduring
popularity and has cast pedro pascal and
bella ramsay in the lead roles of joel
miller and ellie the story centers
around an apocalyptic cordyceps fungal
infection that slowly deteriorates its
host into a ravenous zombie-like
monstrosity joel is a survivor in the
post-apocalyptic landscape who is tasked
with delivering ellie a young girl to an
underground organization known as the
fireflies the scope of the game follows
the bond that joel and ellie develop as
well as the revelations that occur along
their cross-country adventure the hbo
series is sure to offer up a raw
portrayal of the game's themes and
overall plot in pristine live-action
glory
with a metacritic user score of 8.7 out
of a possible 10 how i met your mother
is one of the most popular modern
sitcoms of all time for comparison
friends has a score of 8.5 on the same
site audiences apparently couldn't get
enough of ted mosby telling his children
the story of you guessed it how he met
their mother quite possibly one of the
longest stories a father ever told his
children about anything how i met your
mother went on to inspire memes parodies
and pop culture at large in 2022 the
show receives a spiritual successor in
the form of how i met your father hilary
duff stars as a young sophie while kim
cattrall appears as her grown-up
counterpart once again telling the
fabled story of how she met their father
to her children like how i met your
mother the new series follows a group of
close friends as they come into their
own as young adults and figure out what
they want most out of life if the show
is anything like its predecessor there
will be plenty of hijinks hilarity and
quotable lines along the way in the
immortal words of barney stinson when
the show hits hulu on january 18th
it's gonna be legend wait for it dairy
legendary the ending of game of thrones
was met with weeping and wailing from
certain fans the show's harshest critics
cited a distinct lack of character
development and an apparent rush in
narrative structure just to abruptly
arrive at the show's ham-fisted final
curtain call some fans however wished it
would simply have continued far beyond
the eighth season whatever side of the
fence you sit on perhaps you're willing
to give the brand another shot the
series undeniably captivated the globe
and became one of the most watched high
fantasy epics in television history now
hbo hopes those viewers are ready to
return for the prequel series house of
the dragon the 2022 series is
specifically based on george r martin's
novel fire and blood which details the
history of westeros two centuries before
the events of game of thrones house
targaryen is central to the plot as the
series covers their downfall as one of
the royal families in westeros the cast
is entirely new though some of the
characters may have been referenced
during the game of thrones narrative
from a historical standpoint ultimately
the family known for its ties and
interactions with dragons is certain to
entertain in a wildly dramatic and
bloody fashion as fans have come to
expect
oscar isaac makes his grand entrance
into the marvel cinematic universe with
the debut of the hero moon knight in his
own 2022 disney plus series once again
marvel is plunging deep into its
pantheon of characters that might be
lesser known to the general populace
mark spector is the identity behind the
hero who suffers from disassociative
identity disorder as a former marine and
cia operative he is well versed in the
art of combat and strategy but the comic
book realization of the character often
depicts him attempting to embrace the
moral high ground dc and marvel have
finally begun breaking ground into the
realm of live-action diversity depicting
a hero with a mental illness is another
drop in the bucket engaging audiences
who can relate with the struggle the
driving force behind his superhero
identity is the egyptian moon god consu
but ultimately the character's abilities
are all grounded in his life experiences
as a combatant in armed conflict the
show is sure to offer a fresh take on
the superhero genre with did being a
focal point and the series promises a
lot of action just by the very nature of
the character
one of the biggest video game franchises
of all time halo is set to make its live
action debut on the paramount plus
streaming service in 2022 fans will be
able to sit back and watch a cinematic
retelling of the conflict between
humankind and the alien collective known
as the covenant pablo schreiber from the
wire will portray the man behind the
iconic armor master chief petty officer
john117 the spartan soldier leads the
charge against the alien threat and will
likely be a driving force in the
upcoming live-action series ardent halo
connoisseurs will likely take note that
the voice behind cortana in the game
series jen taylor is reprising her role
for the show according to ign
live-action video game adaptations have
often proved to be critical failures or
at the least divisive only time will
tell whether halo proves to be as
impactful as its source material
hot off the heels of the witcher season
2 netflix plans to satiate fans desire
for more rather quickly compared to the
lengthy two-year gap between season one
and two
it's not too late
this time however audiences will be
transported more than a thousand years
into the past with the witcher blood
origin with geralt's adventures on hold
between seasons blood origin will
portray the first witcher ever created
in fact speaking with entertainment
weekly blood origins showrunner lauren
hizrik said that the prequel will flip
the script on the perception that humans
brought civilization to the elves she
added that the events of the six part
series will shape some of the major arcs
for characters in season three of the
witcher the first teaser for blood
origin debuted during the credits of the
witcher season 2 finale and it let
audiences know that the setting and
action they've come to love remains
intact for the prequel the mini series
is set to release on the streaming
service in 2022
with a steady stream of new marvel
properties hitting disney's streaming
service in 2022 it's high time that
samuel l jackson's nick fury made a
return to the spotlight in secret
invasion nick fury will return alongside
ben mendelsohn's talos and kobe smulders
maria hill the last time we saw nick
fury he was working with the skrulls off
world talos had shape-shifted and played
the role of the former shield director
to aid peter parker in his fight against
mysterio in spider-man far from home
while the skrulls are seemingly allies
in the mcu the comic book story line by
the same name depicts the shape-shifting
aliens capturing and replacing many
superheroes on earth hence the title
secret invasion throughout the series it
comes as a shock and surprise finding
out which characters are not truly
themselves the six part series is sure
to garner a lot of interest once it hits
disney's streaming service in 2022
it's time for the legendary jedi knight
to receive a bit of attention in the age
of streaming services ever since star
wars fans understood that there was a
lengthy gap in obi-wan kenobi's life
missing from the big screen there were
always going to be opportunities to tell
more stories featuring anakin
skywalker's former mentor with ewan
mcgregor back in the role fans are now
primed to see a return of one of the
most beloved jedi warriors in star wars
history they might even learn how
obi-wan kept luke's identity and
presence from the empire concealed all
those years obi-wan kenobi will also see
another famous star wars actor reprise a
former role hayden christensen will
return as darth vader how much of
christensen's face we will actually see
is unknown however
this is the end for you my master
obi-wan kenobi is set ten years after
the third installment of the prequel
series revenge of the sith which
portrayed anakin's transformation into
darth vader once and for all so it
stands to reason that much of
christensen's performance could be
hidden behind his character's iconic
helmet regardless obi-wan kenobi is sure
to please anxious star wars fans in 2022
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]